hi everyone matt here thanks for tuning
in before we get started with this great
episode i'd like to invite you to join
us on linkedin
find the think fast talk smart page and
follow us for conversation updated
information new ideas and a great
opportunity for us to interact
hello there i'm matt abrahams to keep up
with the learning this summer we're
diving back into some of our most
popular episodes think of this as summer
school
as part of our summer learning series
we'll be reintroducing an episode and
pairing it with an assignment for you to
complete fasten your seatbelts and
sharpen your pencils
i always define a reputation
as the echo that precedes you into a
room
and the echo that remains after you
leave
allison kluger's quote has stuck with me
for a long time i'm matt abrahams and i
teach strategic communication at
stanford graduate school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
thanks for joining us for part two of
our summer learning series in part one
we revisited an episode all about
storytelling and humor we heard from
many of you on our linkedin page about
your homework the jokes that you learn
from your life experience
for this episode we're going to talk all
about reputation
i'm joined by jenny luna our executive
producer so jenny tell me what do you
think about reputation
well matt i hear people say all the time
what others think of you is none of your
business or that i shouldn't care what
others think
so i struggle a little bit with the
whole reputation thing i hear you we're
so often told that we shouldn't care
what people think but i'm not so sure i
agree with that
how you present yourself and how other
people perceive you is a critical
element for your success at work and in
life
in one of the very first interviews we
did on this podcast i spoke with allison
kluger a lecturer in strategic
communication here at stanford gsb
allison focuses on how to manage
reputation how to tell your story and
establish your brand
jenny can you share with our listeners
what our homework assignment is for this
episode yeah so something that really
stuck with me from the reputation
episode is when alison mentions the book
reputation rules by daniel dermer she
talks about daniel's trust radar let's
play a quick clip about that from the
episode
so what this trust radar says is that
there are four elements that are really
important to create trust with people
and to either repair your reputation or
make sure your reputation stays positive
and the four axes are really expertise
empathy
commitment and transparency
okay so here's your homework assignment
listeners i want you to draw your own
trust radar draw a quadrant with an x
and y axis put the following words in
the four quadrants expertise empathy
commitment and transparency
now think of an aspect at home or at
work where you are a leader and rank
yourself along the axis
in which areas are you strongest and in
which areas you can improve
we are super excited to see your radar
please share your findings on linkedin
we love drawings yeah snap a photo of
your quadrant and upload it to the post
on our linkedin page about this best of
episode we so look forward to your
responses
now enjoy this episode communicating our
multiple selves how to manage your
reputation
[Music]
i'm thrilled to have my colleague and
fellow gsb lecturer allison kluger here
with me to help better explain what
actions we can take to communicate the
reputation we want others to see us
having
alison has an amazing background she
served as a producer for many tv and
radio shows including good morning
america and the view and she is an
expert on digital media at the gsb she
teaches strategic communication as well
as reputation management strategies for
successful communicators alison i can't
tell you how thrilled i am to have you
here today we worked hard to make this
happen and i'm excited to have our
conversation
i'd like to start by asking uh
three background questions for you
first how do you define reputation
why should we worry about it and how do
others come to learn about our
reputations matt i'm thrilled to be here
thank you so much uh those are great
questions to start with i always define
a reputation
as the echo that precedes you into a
room and the echo that remains after you
leave
and a great reputation is really like
currency
so if it can do the work for you before
you even enter the room you're on the
winning side so if someone says oh my
god you have to meet matt he is so
thorough he is so good at scheduling
interviews
uh he always nobody is saying that
allison but all right he always makes
you feel so good about yourself by the
time you show up people are already
predisposed
to want to like you and to listen to you
so the other end of the echo when you
leave
is kind of the murmurs right oh my god
that was a really great presentation or
he was so funny or she was so intense
whatever it is it's what are they going
to murmur when you leave the room now
you might say well how do you know
it comes back to you someone might say
my friend saw you at this at the speech
that you gave
and i really want to get together to
talk about business
or um oh your reputation proceeds you i
heard that you really know how to
deliver a great presentation it does
come back and then right in the moment
someone might say can i have your
business card can we have lunch can we
have coffee can i introduce you to
someone
so that's the first part about your
question
right i'm curious to know really
how do
we
work to actually build up that echo what
are some of the specific things we can
do when it comes to managing our
reputation is there something around
mindset that we need to think about i
really believe it's about awareness and
the good news is you can change your
reputation
it's a very fluid process and there are
times in our career in our life
where we have to reevaluate who we are
and what we're delivering to the world
you know when you introduced me you you
really hit the nail on the head because
the question about reputation is
is what we're putting out there being
perceived the way we intend
if there's not a match up then you're
kind of in trouble but what you can do
is to be very conscious it's kind of
like what i say for my online digital
class which is be a conscientious
content creator well you have to be
conscious of how you enter a room you
have to be conscious of first
impressions
you have to be conscious of how present
you are
when you're discussing things with
somebody do they feel that you're
distracted and looking over their
shoulders see if someone better's coming
in the room
and you also have to be consistent
and show up as who you are
time and time again
so that way even on your online
reputation like if you're posting very
kind of wacky things that aren't
consistent people won't really get a
sense of you and people are so quick to
judge or create a fixed bias or a
negative bias the way you can avoid that
is to let people know what you stand for
continuously
kind of curate
your your values
so it sounds like people need to be very
mindful and thoughtful about
what they want others to think and
perceive of them and and really sit down
and think about in a detailed way here's
how i want people
to see me or here's what i stand for and
then once that's done
what do you recommend people do how do
you how do you then articulate
that do you create some kind of
catch phrase do you find certain
causes to support how does one
demonstrate those values and themes that
they've identified it's a great question
matt i always worry about
saying like what do you really do
because you want to be as authentically
you as possible sure and i do find that
your reputation is defined by others
so i know how i want to be
but if i'm not realizing that people are
getting it that way i want to be someone
who's kind and open-minded and not
judgmental and a really hard worker
and so the you know the way i will know
that i'm doing that is if i'm at work
and i get a review and they say you know
you're doing this right
or if your friends say you're like such
a great friend because i can tell you
anything so it's kind of like how do you
live your life and again that word
consistency is really important
if you need to create a new reputation
then i think you need to be more mindful
like let's say you're someone who's
always late
you know why did you look at me when you
said i did not okay you know it's it's a
small thing but then you really have to
you know the buzz is like oh my god you
know we have to call the meeting 10
minutes earlier every time because she's
always late you know how do you change
that kind of reputation you set your
alarm and you get there 10 minutes early
every time so you do have to be very
strategic sometimes but for the really
natural qualities that you have
i think you'll be hearing it
through work and friends
and responses to whatever you're putting
out there
right
i know that
two key concepts that you focus on in
your class and we've talked about this
in lots of situations or this notion of
trust in the balance between warmth and
competence can you tell us more about
these ideas you've mentioned consistency
i'm really curious about trust and
warmth and competence yes trust is a
really big area in in reputation and we
use a book called reputation rules by
dearmeyer and he has something that's
called the trust radar
and i love to use this in fact it's
impossible for me to read the news and
not bring in the trust radar when
something is happening some sort of
reputation crisis
so what this trust radar says is that
there are four elements that are really
important to create trust with people
and to either repair your reputation or
make sure your reputation stays positive
and the four axes are really
expertise
empathy
commitment and transparency
i'm sure you've heard of this i'm sure a
lot of business students have heard of
the tylenol
episode way back in the 1980s i think
when tainted the tainted oh i love the
alliteration
the tampered tainted tylenol
so that's true someone was putting you
know cyanide and some tylenol caplets
and there were deaths and the company
tylenol's company they could have just
said it's up to it's a serial killer
it's not our fault but they did the
absolute opposite they took every bottle
off the shelves they said your safety is
the most important thing
return anything you have will pay it
will pay you back your money and then
they made it instead of like a moment
of disaster they made it a moment of
triumph where they develop new tamper
free packaging
so what they showed was first of all
they were very transparent they said you
know we don't know what's going on but
we're going to protect you they were
very committed they put their top ceo to
come and give the message out the
expertise was in developing new
packaging
and they were committed to solving this
problem so on the trust radar they're
hitting everything right
sometimes you see someone who doesn't
respond as well to an emergency they're
kind of like no comment no comment right
that's already breaking the number one
rule of trust just frustrates people
right
so
trust is a is a really big issue because
if i come to you and i'm expecting
something
to and you don't deliver it i'm going to
just reevaluate you in the moment
right right and then the warmth and
competence
that plays into reputation but also
plays into executive presence
which i believe that if you're all data
and you're all kind of
knowledge but without any warmth to
balance it you can come off as arrogant
or know it all or a little poindexter as
we used to say that when we were younger
right and um
and that's not a really great way to be
and also very dry if you're all warmth
then people think oh that person's
really fluffy they don't know they have
no substance
so i really believe the superpower
is to match warmth and competence
um because people want to like you
and people want to trust you
and the more likable you are the more
amiable the more you're
kind of aware of how you're coming off
to people
um
the more people respond to you in a
positive way so as we
now more and more are struggling with
managing reputations
not just in the physical world but in
the virtual world as well with our
presence and all these social media
tools i look at my teenage children and
and i see how many different instances
of themselves there are we were so lucky
growing up we only had to be who we were
in front of people we really were and
that was hard enough it was hard and so
i'm curious do you have any last bits of
advice or guidance that you provide i do
you know i try to teach this to my kids
we have kids similar ages um
the first thing i say is it's not what
happens it's how you choose to deal with
it
because things are going to happen but
it's
it's kind of like it can be the worst
moment of your life or can be a moment
where you triumph like i said or you
turn it around or you accept it or you
do something of value
so don't let what happens define you let
how you choose to deal with it define
you
so i end each one of these with three
questions and i'd love for you i'm i've
been
dying to hear your answers to these
three questions so before we end uh let
me ask the first here if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you've ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title what would
that be i would say
be comfortable with being uncomfortable
there's no way we're all going to be
happy and comfortable 24 hours a day and
to have that expectation is really
selling yourself short so my second
question uh and this i'm also really
fascinated to hear your answer and who
is a communicator that you admire and
why you have had such a variety of
people you've interacted with i'm
curious to know who do you admire
well i can i give two
for you allison too nobody else thank
you so much well my first choice is tyra
banks who i teach a course with
because she is someone who is very
underestimated she's started as a
supermodel she's a brilliant
businesswoman
she's a marketing genius
but what i really love about her and
what i've learned about her in the last
kind of three and a half years of
working with her
is that she's very real
and she really has values that she
stands up for and it kind of covers
everything whatever she's talking to you
she's not afraid to be vulnerable she's
not afraid to uncover the warts
that are beneath someone who has a
standard of beauty
and
she's also very free in sharing her
struggles and how you storytell is
really important as a communicator
so that's the real life thing and then
the other person who i just admire so
much is michelle obama when i heard her
speech
when she was campaigning
for hillary i think i think i got chills
i don't think i've ever seen a better
communicated presentation in my entire
life
that's saying something is she's warm
she's real she's strong she's funny
she's uncompromising
and she's inclusive
and she's not at all fabricated like it
comes from her heart and her soul and
you don't you really feel her spirit and
to me
a great communicator someone who's
authentically themselves
and not afraid to show it
and aware of their audience and aware of
you know how they want to change the
world
both of those women are phenomenal
communicators and and i think they
represent very well the the concepts
you've talked about in terms of building
trust being authentic warm and also
competent
so my final question for you is what are
the first three ingredients that go into
a successful communication recipe
well you're going to laugh because this
is something you teach but i truly
believe it it's aim
it's audience intent and message i don't
care what whether you're going to be in
a one-on-one meeting or a presentation
or a job interview or wooing somebody
you need to know your audience
you have to understand where they're
coming from and it's really putting
yourself in someone else's shoes
initially and then what is the intent of
this communication you're having with
them do you want to entertain do you
want to inform do you want to convince
persuade fundraise whatever it is if
you're not certain on your intent your
message will be confusing and then
finally how do you message
messaging clearly and succinctly and
repeating your message and having it as
a strong opening and a strong closing so
that's the last thing they remember
so aim audience intent and message your
aim is clearly hit the target today
allison i i've thoroughly enjoyed uh
speaking with you your reputation
preceded you and you've only confirmed
it and and i love this notion of
reputation being the echo that comes
before and after and i i hope our
conversation today will echo for
everybody who's listened it certainly
will echo for me thank you so much matt
thanks again for listening to our second
summer learning series episode allison
shares so many useful tips and tricks to
help us manage our reputation now it's
your turn we look forward to seeing your
homework assignment posted to our
linkedin page
thanks and happy learning
this has been another episode of our
think fast talk smart summer learning
series please check out all three
episodes in this series think fast talk
smart the podcast is a production of
stanford graduate school of business
this episode was produced by podium
podcast company jenny luna and me matt
abrahams
find more resources follow and join our
conversation on linkedin by searching
think fast talk smart and please
download and follow wherever you get
your podcasts and be sure to drop us a
review on spotify or apple podcasts
you